always so perceptive about everyone but  yourself  still see couldn't him does welcome home  son why indulging because visits I think  if you ask us guards they will tell you  I was never there  well the Loki is not the boy you once  knew nor are you and I loved you no less  when your father banished you to us do  you ever regret sharing your magic with  know you and your father cast large  shadows I'd hoped by sharing my gifts  with locally that he could find since  time for himself admire your optimism  joking passion I wish I could still  shared now am I to take it by your  present that the nine realms still stand  yes they did I came to get father the  good news and you thought to find him  here you will find him where he's most  at ease